avec otages bruce willis vous redevenez
un héros donc on va faire une interview
antihéros boucherie c'est ce que vous
avez déjà fermer votre gueule devant un
flic qui vous connaît un pv ouais
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenait à
un black alors tant excuse-moi l'échec
bruce willis hockey
est-ce que vous avez déjà fermer votre
gueule devant un flic qui s'en prenaient
un black nom est devant un blague qui
s'en prenait à un flic est ce que vous
avez déjà fait semblant de ne pas
entendre quelqu'un qui vous avez insulté
alors oui vous êtes déjà évanoui
on va voir parce que nous ça nous
arrange lâchement que ce soit un anti
héros quand est-ce que vous avez déjà
porter des chaussettes trouées par
exemple louis nesti de sale nom est ce
que vous avez déjà exigé un cascadeur
pour une scène pourtant sans danger
ah non vous avez déjà demandé à des
techniciens de sortir du plateau au
moment où vous alliez vous mettre tout
nu vous ai déjà eu une panne sexuelle
avec une femme très entreprenante sète
hérault
est-ce que vous avez déjà serré la main
de quelqu'un en sachant qu'il vous
détestez et qui sortait des toilettes
sans se laver les mains est ce que vous
êtes déjà barré avant qu'une de vos
conquêtes ne se réveille
j'ai crié non seulement du doigt le
matin est ce que vous êtes
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà dit à une
fille que c'était la femme de votre vie
pour coucher plus vite avec elle js j'ai
déjà profité qu'une fille soit bourré
pour coucher avec ah ben oui pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux